il y aura un poissard puisque c'est très
simple à chaque fois la personne va
prendre un ingrédient haut et va le
mettre dans ce mixeur et en soute à lire
à chercher une carotte
ici l'eau celui qui aura la plus petite
carotte de voix brard tout le mix and
away we made you lie non non c'est qui
va se faire
julien m'a dit julien tu penses que tu
veux comme ingrédients et tu le mets
dedans déjà ce que notre conscience que
c'est très bon voilà voilà pour le
transit la commande à l'éval 28 pas dire
qu'on va maintenant très bien qu anne
frèches effet et julien tu vas prendre
une carotte le prendre car je la tire
bien sûr tu tires la carotte plutôt
habilement une bosse ça fait longtemps
qu'on ne l'avait pas vu
[Rires]
alors il fallait pas dire la dette
allez on va dire voilà a pas obligé de
citer fait on est obligé de citer
d'autres crème chocolatée mont blanc et
autres
merci sédégo allez c'est parti ben aziza
tu prends tout de suite d'apprendre la
carotte c'est toujours nous et pour
noisiel carottes souvenirs récents cgil
a mis un quart d'heure c'est un petit
peu trop mal choisie comme massive a
terminé une carotte qui l'ignoble
choisissez bien
mais du temps je veux dire ces carottes
comme dans la vie c'est mon fils aîné
sur ces cas ni pour l'instant c'est
toujours apprendre à choisir l'accès de
l'avocat tout à tous une partie à nice
et un accès je rappelle que devra voir
l'ensemble du mixeur vas-y là c'est
maxime dany tu te mets là font là soit
tu te mets là pour éduquer les revenus
des carottes se bat côté du mix est là
et tu mets ta carottes bien entendu elle
est au mitard
alors allez chercher votre carotte pour
l'instant c'est maxime guennic est la
plus petite carotte vous vous en doutiez
chez vous allez c'est bon ça sent bon
maxime elodie fontan kate avec nous la
pauvre elle était venue
bref on a mis un peu de sucre et je te
mets ta que le gars qui va voir ça ou la
fille c'est impossible
attention attention elodie choisissez il
reste quatre joueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention sera pas les habitants et plus
comme en grèce deux tireurs haye et de
tirs williams a également noyé
est ce que vous allez voir une petite
carotte qu'elodie c'est tout à l'heure
et enfin je m'attends petit peu de
vinaigre vite je suis plus petit que
tous attendent horaire l'organe a dit
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on ne fait pas attention ne triche pas
on mesurera les carottes censure année
cyril reste dans mon coeur souvent les
gens qui sortent vraiment réussir les
compense quelque chose appelée tu as
besoin quelques des petites carottes
payant et ma famille les nbic pas fait
attention si c'est pas vous faut les
attirer
elle a été raccourcie la mienne nasa
soit réparé faire jaillir la plus petite
c'est la plus fine oui elodie a désolé
de te le dire mais tu as la plus petite
carotte alors à temps vers un dernier
truc lui faire un dernier truc
typhi je vais mixer
et après je vous dirais l'émission a
commencé là malheureusement sardines
dalet à roquefort c'est bien comme tu es
fille tu te rajoute un peu de chance
vous aurez fait un petit profit
tu sais que tu es un ami il va le faire
depuis des années je le croyais tu as
bien fait deux trois petites filles
mettre face à ses responsabilités
soit tu dis oui je vais boire ce lait on
vas tu dis papa c'est quoi ce verre j'ai
fait appel à un ami qui est mon estomac
qui m'a dit voilà faisait choisi syrie
[Applaudissements]
ces courageuses vous êtes un ami et pour
paris fait le malin mais quitte à leur
tour est la promo la rada minarets pour
une fois que ça tombe sur la gueule rien
dérapages chef sera pas là non ça voilà
le cocktail je vais en boire un peu bas
silva joue dit bah oui je suis obligé
jeu en boire un peu puisque j'avais
promis pour fifi aller heureusement je
vois le vrai
horrible bah ça aux fantômes lundi les
schémas australe ont directement ses
best of mais quelle horreur mais vous
pouvez pas savoir si c'est si oui
accordez-moi 30 secondes venait avec moi
samedi à 14h30 au stade de france et la
plus grande dictée du monde organisée
par rachid santaki n'a dit merci le sien
[Applaudissements]